In the previous section, we covered fitting metahuman topology to metahuman presets.
Another approach is to use the Mesh to Metahuman workflow, with the standard Mesh or Template Mesh option also referred to as Conformed Mesh.
In this section, we will review some important terminology that relates to metahuman identity conforming,
and go over what a metahuman identity asset is, what conforming means and how it works, what exporting the conformed mesh means and how it can be used.
A metahuman identity asset contains the template of a head mesh and a reference to the matching rig that is generated from the input source data such as a scanner sculpt.
Conforming refers to the process of configuring the metahuman identity to approximate the volume that is found from the metahuman preset database.
The results may not match the source data precisely as this process uses the metahuman standard topology.
The conformed mesh of the metahuman identity that has been generated can be exported directly from the metahuman identity asset window, locally on the user's workstation.
Since this is of metahuman topology, it can be used for refitting any lost details to the scanner sculpt.
In the next section, we will go through a hands-on exercise where we will export the conformed mesh from the metahuman identity asset window.